rémy bénichou 32 ans travaille dans la
recherche et le développement d'une
société médicale atteint de nanisme
c'est un passionné de sport depuis
l'enfance ça fait maintenant cinq ans
qu'il pratique la course à pied 5 années
pour franchir différents paliers pour
l'instant j'ai il est vrai qu'en fait
les objectifs j'y suis allé petit à
petit depuis le début de la pratique de
la course à pied où l'objectif était de
faire un kilomètre après 5 kilomètres et
je vais donc du 10 au semi marathon et
du coup au marathon où j'ai du coup j'ai
pu rencontrer
mon cinquième il ya deux semaines il ya
deux il ya deux trois semaines sur le
marathon de paris avec cinq marathons à
son actif et plusieurs trail rémy a
souvent dû se surpasser sa plus grande
fierté le gr 20 en corse c'est vraiment
une expérience
c'était avec ses 180 km de traversée et
que j'ai pu faire en 13 jours et ça
c'est une de mes plus belles expériences
que j'ai également pu partager sur les
en commande il ya deux parties à la
partie nord et la partie sud et que j'ai
pu aussi partie partagée avec une de mes
grandes soeurs et c'est vrai que c'est
c'était vraiment très bon souvenir pour
faire ses courses qui sont d'autant plus
difficiles en raison de son handicap il
doit être attentif aux signaux donnés
par son corps surtout à l'écouté de mon
corps je sais pas ce que c'est que je
fais vraiment attention voilà au niveau
de ma condition physique au niveau de
mes articulations mais pour rien au
monde le coureur n'arrêterait sa routine
sportive il est vrai que le sport comme
comme les personnes valides je pense que
le sport est important ça permet de voix
de pouvoir se développer de pouvoir
dépasser ses limites d'apporter une
certaine une certaine estime de soi par
rapport aux objectifs atteints dans sa
ligne de mire rémy bénichou vise d'ici
les deux prochaines années un trail sur
l'île de la réunion 160 km pour 11000
mètres de dénivelé son nom la diagonale
des fous